und jetzt eine grosse premiere knapp
sechs monate liegt nämlich die
flutkatastrophe im aartal zurück und wir
erinnern uns alle an diese schrecklichen
bilder doch was hat sich seitdem getan
wir haben unseren ganz besonderen
reporter vor ort milo knapper der
neunjährige hat sich nämlich bei uns
gemeldet und uns gebeten dass er von vor
ort berichten darf
hallo ich bin's wieder eure milow und
heute berichte ich euch
über meine schule was die flut hier so
gebracht hat die klassenräume wurden
zerstört alle flure
die dental grundschule liegt in trümmern
wie so viele schulen im aartal für
kinder reporter milow und seinem kumpel
lionel ist der besuch hier wie eine
zeitreise eine reise in die heile welt
vor der flut
vor allem ein raum liefert viele
erinnerungen an den letzten schultag
hier ein tag kurz vor den sommerferien
hier sind wir in meinem alten
klassenräumen und da stehen sogar noch
die hausaufgaben
wer weiß noch am letzten tag sind wir
sogar noch wandern gewesen
dann sind wir auch noch ohne zeugnissen
die sommerferien reingegangen es war
nicht richtig doof wenn ihr montag meine
mutter war richtig sauer auf mich weil
sie dachte ich habe zwar ich hab das
zeigt dass ihr nicht gezeigt
die ganze situation mit der neuen schule
passt kumpel lionel gar nicht
probiert dann im moment zur schule ich
gehe im moment nach abrückte schule und
es gefällt bin ich gut weil die bußmann
dauert zu lange eigentlich musste ich ja
fünf minuten zur schule gehen weil ich
in altenburg gewohnt habe und jetzt muss
jetzt 40 bis zu 40 minuten im bus fahren
bei dem besuch durch das zerstörte
altenburg gehen die zwei jungs auch in
das alte zerstörte haus von lionel und
seiner familie
wo sind wir hier gerade
wir sind bei mir zu hause im wohnzimmer
teil stand richtig viel wasser drin das
sofort sich umgestellt und vieles mehr
es war schrecklich
hattest du auch angst
[Musik]
naja wenn das also ein bisschen mehr das
wasser gestiegen ist oder ob es wieder
angefangen zu regnen ob es stärker
geworden ist und so
wahllos bericht zeigt deutlich hier im
aartal ist auch gut ein halbes jahr nach
der flut noch jede menge zu tun
ja ganz berührende einblicke die wir da
von milow bekommen haben und jetzt ist
und seine mutter zugeschaltet frau
jennifer knapp hallo frau knapp hat
vielleicht sagen ihm einmal beschreiben
wie geht es meiner jetzt nach der flut
also milow hat
schlechte tage jetzt darf man aber nicht
vergessen wir persönlich also unser haus
ist nicht betroffen
dementsprechend hat weil ein rückflug
ort wo er sich geborgen fühlt wo wir
nach hause kommen kann das haben
natürlich so viele andere kinder hier im
abfall nicht von denen ich gar nicht
wissen möchte wie renault geht
was erzählte einmal über seine freunde
über die anderen kinder
in der schule kommt jetzt hält er viel
dass die kinder zum teil sehr aktiv sind
dass sie schnell wütend werden dass sie
sehr aufbrausend sind und ich denke das
ist auch eine reaktion auf das
zusammenspiel bruna und vorstand nach
wie sieht die schule denn überhaupt aus
in die schule wo er jetzt aktuell geht
oder seine reise wie die containerschule
ja die containerschule die ist auf jeden
fall eine verbesserung
zudem war vorher eingegangen ist die auf
raich möglichkeit im april
es ist halt eine containerschule wie
steht auf einen platten sind keine
spielgeräte da ist ein spielzeug die
müssen halt damit umgehen lernen leider
nicht frau knabbert wer hilft den leuten
vor ort also ihn kommt da noch hilfe an
macht sie das auch wütend dass teilweise
ist ein bisschen in vergessenheit gerät
das man sich dass man das gefühl
manchmal also die solidarität nach wie
vor ungebrochen auch den kindern
gegenüber es gibt ganz viele
institutionen ganz viele privatmenschen
die unheimlich vier versuchen den
kindern eine freude zu machen mit
weihnachten im schuhkarton mit
geschenken mit briefen mit patenschaften
von anderen schulen aber wovon augen hat
man das gefühl das wird gar nicht mehr
in der containerschule an über liegt ein
schreiben vor dass aufgrund der enge der
containerschule die nachbetreuung in
dieser container schule an die stadt
sind wir sind so dass alle kinder die
betreut werden muss dann beide eltern
arbeiten gehen mit einem linienbus
wieder zwölf kilometer im
katastrophengebiet rhein fahren müssen
um dort in einem container nach
schulisch betreut werden und dann
nachmittags wieder mit dem linienbus
trichter nach hause zu fahren das sind
so sachen irgendwie hakt es an allen
ecken man hat immer das würde es geht
ein schritt nach vorne um dann wieder
zwei schritte nach hinten gehen
ganz herzlichen dank für diese eindrücke
die sie uns geschildert haben und
begrüßen sie uns unseren nachwuchs
reporter milow vielen dank